good morning Hank it's Thursday January
18th yes if you're wondering why I'm
doing my happy dance because I've lost
three pounds this week I'm only 12
pounds away from being a light
heavyweight according to the
International Boxing Federation yes
unfortunately I am also doing my sad
dance so I may have to extend my
deadline by a couple of days which is
particularly humiliating considering I
shared it in public on our video blog
but I think I will definitely be done by
Wednesday
definitely by Wednesday definitely by
definitely by Wednesday next Friday by
the very latest sometimes when I take a
morning off from writing I like to go
outside walk through the park and play
this game the game is called who's
outside on the Upper West Side of
Manhattan nanny nanny rich kid nanny
nanny rich kid nanny nanny rich kid
funny dog nanny rich kid nanny rich
kidney rich kid fight all